et on va accueillir tout de suite notre
père noël mystère pour autres mises à
mal non
merci père noël mystère vers noël
mystère alors c'est pas le même père
noël que tout est le nom nom de ceux qui
cherchent à perdre et le mystère vous
verrez ça tout à l'heure alors vous
allez découvrir votre cadeau isabelle
morini-bosc qu'est ce que c'est alors
ouais si vous pouviez vous maniez le cul
permis de rs 2 photos d'une jolie jeune
femme donc pas moi et a écrit permis de
conduire fac similé parmi vous exposez
votre permis de conduire maintenant
qu'on laisse jamais passer jamais et
bien isabelle j'ai fait il me semble
permis de conduire le mec m'a peloter
s'est jamais revenue là le mec vous à
peloter légal n'était pas connu et bien
est ce que vous aimeriez repasser le
permis de conduire il faut combien que
le son c'est bizarre oui c'est ce que je
disais tout à la wii alors oui et il
faut beaucoup de leçon et des leçons
année parce que si je vous offrait de
permis de conduire ça vous ferait
plaisir
ben oui surtout si vous venez demain
pour les leçons ouais moi je lève mais
chez joly astag et pmp noël on va offrir
le permis de conduire à un
téléspectateur et à isabelle morini-bosc
isabelle morini bosc
il va falloir que vous fassiez une
épreuve similaire très particulière pour
gagner votre permis de conduire vous
allez allez sur le parking de des mâles
en malaisie isabelle allégé on va vous
amener là bas
vous allez voir nos défis
le décès d'isabelle morini-bosc je crois
qu'ils s'appellent morini bosc est en
place
isabelle morini bosc est d'avoir tout de
suite de twilight ont regardé alors
voilà isabelle morini bosc et dans une
voiture à la preuve d'auto école avec
est là parce que pour les pédales elle
va devoir faire un partout isabelle
morini-bosc ma parcours particulier elle
à devoir slalomer entre des obstacles
voyez ce que vous voyez là sur apoula
tendu vous allez comprendre pourquoi
poule parce qu isabelle morini bosc
il y à une baignoire on a enlevé le toit
de la voiture et il y à une baignoire au
dessus à cette fois qu'elle bougera trop
la voiture c'est la même parfois tout de
suite bien sûr à chaque fois qu'elle
voudra trop il y aura deux loups qui va
tomber en à 6 le niveau d'eau s'il vous
plaît jérôme si le niveau d'eau est
au-dessous de la bande rouge elle perd
le permis s'il reste au dessus elle
gagne le perdre d'accord il ya des
poissons il ya de tout voilà alors les
séries dont et bien sûr elle fera gagner
aussi un tweet au ce1 qui partira avec
le permis
merci si il aboutir d'accord apparaît
comprend le français yoplait ont enlevé
les enlever les chéris merci donc
isabelle est ce que vous êtes prêtre ma
série j'ai rien compris mais je suis
prête nom isabelle est ce qu'on peut
voir le parcours s'il vous plaît jérôme
revon le parcours qu'elle va devoir
faire regarder voyez à tous par quad va
devoir envers ce parent ou aller retour
et il y aura également des animaux sur
le parcours ouais d'accord gérez vous
voyez qu'il ya des animaux rend plus là
faites attention
isabelle dans un instant vous allez
devoir vous allez prendre de l'eau sur
les chevaux et isabella isabelle
j'allais prendre de l'eau sur les
cheveux d'accord mais c'est ça ouais
donc enlevé enlever leur enlever le
bonnet mais pourquoi alors 5 heures du
matin
c'est la radio
c'est la radio isabelle c'est pour le
permis c'est pour gagner le permis
bacheri s'est dit qu'ils nous emmerdent
lannion d'éveil isabelle on va vous
retrouver bond à vous retrouver dans cet
état pour le parcours c'est la première
fois de la deuxième fois beaucoup
d'usagers belle c'est la première fois
qu'elle conduit merci en tout cas c'est
où les pédales je sens que ça ça va être
ce sera dans un instant sur 2500 matin
la finance on va retrouver
nous partons vire tout de suite il
appelle morini-bosc isabelle morini bosc
qui va passer le permis de conduire qui
a peut-être gagné son permis de conduire
elle un parcours à faire isabelle
morini-bosc on va voir le parcours
jérôme revon elle a une baignoire au
dessus de la voiture il ya de l'eau qui
va tomber
non mais c'est l'eau passe au dessous du
niveau voilà de la bande rouge perdu
pour le permis elle joue pour a perdu
pour elle et elle joue pour quelqu'un
qu'on appelle tout de suite aussi qui
veut avoir son permis qui veut conduire
son permis c'est parti on appelle et je
vous rappelle pouvez toujours twitté je
vous dis encore rien séjour au ski quoi
faire gagner aussi dans un instant les
syriens va faire gagner un séjour aussi
grâce à jean michel bessonneau rien mais
son oreillette allez allez allez
fabuleuse isabelle saveur merci les
traders c'est des bonnes nouvelles c'est
ma fenêtre butembo s'en fout elle veut
dire ça mais là vous êtes en cdd moto
j'entends peur allô allô allô oui qui
est l appareil
salut jessica c'est cyril hanouna sa
machine
comment ça va toi sa mohammadia mahdieh
j'étais inscrite sur twitter tu nous
regardes actuellement oui à babylone en
déclin est un amour ça va tu passes une
belle soirée ma chérie très très très
très bonne tu fais quoi dans la vie tu
as bien raison a besoin de gestionnaires
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde où les
chiffres ont pris le pas sur les lèvres
oui moi oui ma belle-mère et avec qui la
lie avec mon copain et massy il
s'appelle comment silva et chloé silva
et crouy s'appelait de salut baba salut
ma chérie tu habites ou à puteaux pire
est passé et à deux pas oui oui et tu
veux passer ton père me tapote ont
permis non j'ai pas demandé à mon père
mais d'un coup trop cher je vais
peut-être t'offrir ton permis tout de
suite ma chienne harry ton permis je
vais te l'offrir mais il va falloir qu
isabelle morini-bosc soit bonne il
c'est la première fois qu'elle conduise
à belmont haut niveau ce qu elle va
devoir faire un parcours aller-retour
signe encore de l'eau à la fin du
parcours au dessus de la bande rouge le
permis sera gagné isabelle attention est
ce que vous êtes prête isabelle way
elle est aimable
comme vous pouvez le constater la zone
dames et aimable tu peux juste réunir le
personnel d'airtel à 4 heures du matin
s'il risque de voir arriver une année
avec un coulis mais ces succès de sa
revue the axis la troisième elle
s'appelle comment elle s'appelle votre
votre pote de toute l'école elle
s'appelle audrey ah oui voilà j'avais
déjà oublié son prénom adresse
tu prenais les pédales au mot bah je
sais que non mais bon allez on y va vous
l'avez expliqué comment conduire pas du
tout non
on a cassé tout le temps à régler le son
au calme après ben ça va c'est beau
bassin petite léonie bas c'est parti
ne mettez pas les animaux sa structure
et ça ça suffit comme ça pas les animaux
par les animaux assez sinon maintenant
pour l'instant ça passe
à
on regardera les hauts falaises à
melbourne et des restaurants de locaux
instance et gagnac l'a bien vite je
viens tu vas là alors occupé par tous et
pas fait ça va aller tourner tout mais
la prod de takanobu dû arrêter la
musique hawzi arrêter la musique aller
qu'on les entende alors isabelle causé à
tour et de mystères à les appels soit on
veut juste qu'on s'est tous dit stop
mais tu sais que je vais raconter ses
partenaires dans sa tête soit au volant
juste la tête
elles ont peu plus et moralement et bas
et alors ça fait maintenant brûler du
papier bulle sur l'or c'est plus ma
fille tu ne fais pas tu utilises le
froid comme tu veux pour que le long de
l'arête aventure est quand même toujours
rien
et c'est tout à leur honneur revient au
point de départ
bref on veut le point de départ on y va
alors marché
allez voir l'impact et aux gémonies pour
vous pour l'instant saccadé dans la saga
des par ici par ici là à les situer et
accélère un peu pour qu'on aille vite
parce que là il ya trop de bordel là
haut
attendant qu'on l'entende info nature
d'apple
attendez
attendez avant de rester on peut
vérifier les chéris si le permier gagner
a priori c'est bon pour l'image qu'elle
est permis et ce superbe album je suis
catalan et de père inconnu
c'était riche mais qu'est-ce qu'il a
jusque là bas alors là isabelle oui vous
avez gagné le permis de conduire pété
alain dudon
j'avais jamais conduit elle est partie
un poil est revenue
et
elle est venue celle là vous lui la
parade à l'oma pour la conduite elle est
revenue sur calais ça veut dire que tu
as oublié un truc de ouf la pauvre
monsieur monitrice d'atelier
allo
oh
alors voilà donc eu trop alors qu'est-ce
qu'il est magnifique aux leurs audrey
bachy bonjour ça va bien ça va alors la
santé
attendez attendez elle sur le poisson
saab en grèce et navré je suis désolé
elle a bien compris
ben je suis pas sûr en ferry ohlala il
va bien j'aurai mais si je joue l'hymne
petit nom rayé j'ai une petite mort
je vous en ai je vous offre votre permis
de conduire
vous savez où des boules carrées
oui
on veille au grain je vais vous offrir
au gré une tablette numérique
non mais c'est vrai c'est jack nation
bien que ces magnifiques tables à pique
mairie si c'est pour moi le permis c'est
pour vous comme ça ça me sort j'espère
un quoi et vous signale que je l' ai
quand même ramener la voiture oui c'est
le suppléa par douchez